salut aujourd'hui je suis avec astrid
astrid on s'est rencontré un an dans mon
spectacle c'était au théâtre sans nom je
crois exactement les premières dates de
tournée du spectacle
elles peuvent dès vendredi et le
vendredi c'est quoi c'est le jour de
l'euro millions j'ai envie qu'on joue
avec ça d'accord je vais te demande et
astrid par alors aux millions donc
d'imaginer un d'imaginer ce que tu
achèterais soit en voyage soit comme
objet tu gagnais à leurs eaux minérales
c'est facile mais tu peux me piéger en
part en prenant un râteau a yo yo ou
n'importe quoi ou en décidant d'aller en
vacances à dunkerque ça c'est ton choix
exactement je veux poser la caméra là
comme ça on pourra bien se voir tous les
deux on est vraiment dans la rue les
copains j'ai juste besoin de deux oui
c'est clair c'est de la stricte de chez
street j'essaie de faire rapide parce
que je ne coupe plus ces passages là
parce qu'on a accusé de trop couper dans
le coeur même du tour et que en fait
j'avais des en fait je sais qu'il
faudrait pas que je tienne compte de ça
chaque fois mais j'en tiens compte c'est
plus fort que moi j'ai besoin de justes
de recentrer un tout petit peu de
verrouiller est ce que est ce que c'est
un voyage oui c'est un voyagiste
d'accord ok donc il va falloir que je
trouve le pays en fait c'est sa vraie ça
ok je vais chercher ce pays là astrid
je vais pas te poser de question citée y
aller pas y aller parce qu'on pourrait
penser que j'ai discuté avec toi donc
j'ai juste demandé déjà de ressentir toi
comment tu te sentirais là bas est ce
que tu te sentirais bien jus de
ressentir un peu de me dire ok on sentit
à ce qu'il se sentirait bien au chaud au
froid ou un peu stressé parce que
c'était une blague que tu m'avais me
des choses c'est bon c'est bon d'accord
ok on est plutôt des temps ça va on est
plutôt détendue ok
c'est de dire des choses ouais je vais
faire des affirmations tu me réponds
jamais tu peux me répondre que
mentalement
si tu as envie de lui formuler une
réponse qu'il a fait dans ta té voilà
comment faire taire à ce rythme on va
bien donc il répond que dans sa tête
c'est peut-être dans un pays chaud c'est
peut-être peut-être qu'on parle français
peut-être qu'on ne parle pas français
peut-être
t'as vu c'est dur on ne pas répondre je
dois faire 2008 je suis ok c'est
peut-être plus à l'ouest de la france
c'est-à-dire en traversant l'atlantique
où c'est plutôt de l'autre côté je me
dis rien ok
parce que là c'est pas toi même j'ai une
petite idée
j'ai peut-être quand même décidé de
faire un lettre par lettre dont j'ai
toujours le bloc-notes quelque part oui
et un crayon est ce que j'ai un client
is it ok je vais noter mes premières
impressions et croient pas le pas de
pays en lui même
je vous fait voir que à vous est ce que
tu peux me dire s'il fait chaud ou froid
chaud est ce que tu peux me dire son
parc français non instant j'étais à
chaleur est pas français
c'est ça que vous ai fait voir chaleur
est pas français c'est mal écrit mais
c'est ce que j'avais ok pour moi c'est à
l'est de la france au travail ne survole
pas la mer et on va de l'autre côté je
pense avoir bon pour moi on part du côté
de l'asie
elle ne sait plus moi non plus j'aime
puisque je vais essayer de trouver la
première là tu pense juste à la première
lettre appliquée en poupe au niveau vol
simple un petit juste avant ou juste
après un geste pas encore tout à fait
ok j'avais créé ici est ce que tu peux
me dire exactement dans quel pays tu
partirais si gagner ce soir à l'euro
millions compte ayons en thaïlande en
thaïlande
c'est pas gagné pour la thaïlande mais
je te souhaite gagner ce soir à l'euro
millions
si jamais tu as joué que moi aussi je
rêve de gagner à l'euro millions mais en
fait je ne joue pas donc je risque pas
de gagner tout de suite énorme merci il
n'y a pas plus strict
en réalité je te partiro théâtre on
n'avait pas le temps de faire la vidéo
et puis on s'est dit on l'a fait on a
fait pas on se retrouve dans la rue en
train de la faire
si vous avez aimé la vidéo n'hésitez pas
à me le faire savoir en nous laissant un
petit et faire le puissant mais on est
vendredi le vendredi c'est donc toujours
un tour de mentalist que je fais à
quelqu'un je vous fais participer à ça
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la
chaîne vous pouvez aussi laisser un
petit commentaire et le mental blog
c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
alors rendez vous demain à 11 heures
pour le prochain vendée globe
ciao
c